until 1943 cancel takeoff plans so far
this year there have been at least six
aircraft close calls that have rattled
both Aviation officials and travelers
you got the runway yet we're going
around one of the wind traffic going
across the runway
some safety officials say the increase
in Collision warnings might be explained
in part by pilots and air traffic
controllers grappling with the rise in
post-pandemic traffic here's a breakdown
of one of this year's near collisions
and what the busiest airport in the
world does to prevent close calls like
it
on February 4th at Austin Bergstrom
International Airport a FedEx plane was
cleared to land around 6 40 AM local
time it was still mostly dark and
visibility was poor due to weather
conditions when the FedEx plane was
approximately three miles away an air
traffic controller cleared a Southwest
flight to depart that same Runway as the
FedEx plane was Landing its Pilots
noticed the Southwest flight was still
on the runway Southwest sport
Aesthetics is on the go so the FedEx
Pilots initiated a go-around and safely
landed 12 minutes later but this could
have been a disaster the Southwest
flight had 128 people on board a FedEx
spokeswoman said the company appreciated
the efforts from its flight crew to land
the Austin flight safely and in a
message to employees Southwest Chief
Executive Bob Jordan commended the
Southwest crew and said the airline
would fully participate in the
investigation the FAA and NTSB are
investigating six serious Runway
incursions that have occurred so far
this year these incidents show how
important air traffic control is in
keeping planes safe so to understand how
it works we went to the world's busiest
airport
this is the air traffic control tower at
Hartsfield-Jackson Atlanta International
Airport it's responsible for the
airspace approximately five miles out
and 4 000 feet above the airport if
we're really busy and you're working the
clearer takeoff Runway you could have 20
airplanes in mind that are all on your
frequency at once Drew Buckman has been
an air traffic controller for almost 18
years you're looking for those little
abnormalities here and there and you
can't help it anymore it's just that's
just what you're trained to do here Air
Traffic Control towers are managed by
the FAA Atlanta's Tower operates 24 7
due to its high volume but smaller
airports sometimes go uncontrolled when
volume is low though Pilots can still
communicate with the terminal radar
approach control facility or an air
Route traffic control center if needed
controllers in Atlanta juggle around
2100 flights a day so they're only
allowed to work in the tower for two
hours at a time there are three main
positions that controllers work in
Atlantis Tower the local control are the
tower controllers that are working
airplanes on each individual Runway
until the 398 r1265
ground controllers are doing what the
title suggests and you're working
airplanes on the ground
and then we do have a third position
which is called clearance delivery and
they're the ones who are giving the
clearances to the pilots either
electronically or by voice here's what
that process looks like for a plane
departing from Atlanta
foreign
aircraft is ready to taxi clearance
delivery creates a flight progress strip
that has key information like the type
of aircraft and its departure gate the
proposed time is here it is in Zulu time
which is the standard time used across
the aviation industry it's requested
final altitude is going to be 37 000
feet all this information helps
controllers keep track of where every
plane at the airport is going to avoid
collisions next clearance delivery
slides that strip over to the ground
controller
who puts the strips in a sequence
this is the order in which planes will
the runway once they get the aircraft
taxied out and it's in the order they
want it to be in then they'll switch it
over to local control who will see scan
the barcode on the flight strip and
clear the plane for takeoff
before controllers can work with real
planes in the tower they spend six to
eight weeks training here in the
simulator
Southwest 1042 where they practice
working in all kinds of weather
conditions like rain and fog in those
foggy situations when I can't see out
the window this radar here is going to
give me the tools that I need to be able
to see what's actually happening outside
of the tower controllers also use this
Airborne radar to monitor planes in the
air what we look at here is tell us
which Runway they're going to land on
the type of aircraft the altitude and
the speed of each aircraft as well this
information helps controllers keep
aircraft a safe distance apart in the
air somewhere between three and eight
miles depending on the weight of the
aircraft in that near Collision in
Austin Texas the two planes ended up
approximately 100 feet from each other
according to preliminary data from the
national Transportation safety board
in all situations the FAA says
communication between pilots and air
traffic controllers is key
pilots and air traffic controllers have
to be proficient in the use of the
international civil aviation
organization's standard phraseology the
typical ones are clear for takeoff in
clearland those are the ones people know
go around means cancel your approach
clearance we're going to send you around
and you're going to come back and land
again some commands require a specific
response from the pie whenever we tell
them to hold short of Runway 2-6 right I
need for them to read that exact
phraseology back which tells me that
they understand that that Runway is
active and then they cannot cross that
Runway until they get further clearance
but hearing the correct read back from
the pilot isn't always enough for
example on February 27th an air traffic
controller instructed a pilot too
Runway and the pilot read back the
instructions clearly but began a takeoff
role instead
controllers also have a lot of FAA
guidelines and regulations they need to
follow and this is it the
7110.65 is well people like to call our
Bible controllers like to call it 0.65
but this is everything that is required
for us in order to do our jobs on a
daily basis in light of the recent close
calls the FAA held a safety Summit in
March are we emphasizing efficiency over
safety initial information suggests that
more mistakes than usual are happening
across the system on runways
at Gates when planes are pushing back in
control towers and on flight decks the
FAA issued a safety alert a week later
calling on airlines to exercise
continued vigilance joint FAA industry
groups have stepped up efforts to
analyze and counter the trend according
to industry documents and officials
involved officials haven't issued
emergency orders or mandated other
changes to carrier operations yet and
they don't think there are imminent
risks to passengers but safety experts
say they are concerned that potential
Collision risks could continue to rise
still Buckman says controllers are
trained to deal with unusual situations
which can happen from time to time
there's always a plan B there's always a
plan C you always have to be planning
for what's going to happen next
[Music]